à paris avec tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
soubie
c'est le fruit d'une collaboration avec
heidi rica qui est une chanteuse
américaine qui vient de détroit on n'a
qu'à l'aube a collaboré ensemble sur mon
dernier album vers un autre matin où
elle est venue chanter sur une chanson
qui s'appelle you say you say et elle
m'a demandé pour son christmas album de
composer un duo avec elle donc elle est
venue tout droit de détroit pour
composent ensemble ensemble cette
chanson et voilà donc on a sorti le
single cette année
on a imaginé voilà une américaine qui
fait pour le new yorkaise qui fait son
son tour du monde et qui arrivent en
france tombe amoureuse d'un français et
les deux voilà les deux ont une espèce
de nostalgie et et ne souhaite qu'une
seule chose c'est de se retrouver voilà
le rendez-vous parfait pour se retrouver
ce sera un noël à paris quoi on est
vraiment tombé dans le dans la chanson
romantique
on reçoit une touriste américaine où
est-ce qu'on l'emmène emmène bien
évidemment à paris on va en votre cas
des rohan où va ce champs elysées on va
au marché de noël et voilà l'idée était
vraiment de rentrée en plein dans la
chanson et d'illustrer la chanson à
travers les images
ont fait un mini album un ep pop qui
sera pas forcément en rapport avec noël
et qui va sortir au printemps on a tout
enregistré à elle est venue en france
pendant un mois et demi et pendant un
mois et demi on a on a bossé tous les
jours pour faire un album de noël et
ensuite un mini album tous les deux